is marriage outdated in 2022. why are
you looking why you swear when you look
at me did you say that I was looking at
the panel actually I looked at him too
but I looked at both yukes here first no
I just okay she know what I think no you
go you go first no no ways I don't even
know I think anymore these people been
just
out there I think the law has made it
really really unappealing for men I
think there's no need for a man I I I
know I keep going on about my religious
belief but if you've got religion I can
understand why you get married but even
then I don't think you should do it
legally but if you haven't got any
religious reasons or anything like that
I don't understand why anybody man or
woman would get married because it's
it's designed to make you turn against
each other the law just puts you against
each other and it's a horrible way to do
it would you have a family without
marriage not without an Islamic one
though but without illegal yeah yeah
what about you two
um personally
um religious wise I feel like yeah
marriage is is needed but you need to
um commit to someone in the eyes of God
you know what I'm saying and in front of
your people that you know I'm saying you
know you know what I'm saying so you
dedicate to each other it's more like a
um how can I say it's I think it's more
official that's that's why I feel anyway
I think no idea of it is nice if you're
lucky enough to find someone that you
can just fully trust and be with forever
then great but
obviously for a lot of people it doesn't
work out I mean
foreign
I think it's just a western problem
really and truly
um
I believe if you're in a society where
um religious values or any sort of
um General consensus where people have
um equal values and set rules I think in
that kind of society yeah you can
probably make it work but in a society
where we have the kind of settings where
women are paid to leave that kind of
thing and all of that it just makes it
really really hard because you could you
could literally have a good marriage
going and then years down the line
something happens and then the woman
sees as an opportunity to leave and
that's how we see the billionaires
coming out in the
I'm curious from the man
do you guys want to get married
so um yeah um you know I want to get
married like so but
the manuscript knows I want to get mad
they don't feel marriage over here but
I'll explain so basically I
ever since we started it's been about it
I was talking about the other options I
think I've been more open to some of the
other options like what you're saying as
well about me married in the in a
religious way but maybe not like that
legal way whatever only because of all
the stories and everything that goes
with it but I believe in institutional
marriage and what it represents and the
family unit because my parents have been
married over 40 years I got um
four other siblings they're all married
an older child so I come from that unit
so I'm the only one that's not married
so I do believe in it but I just think
the more and more I do this and the more
and more I probably listen to people and
the people that I've been married you
know people that have come in with good
intention and but then again like King
was saying over there like I just think
in a western world when you have the
traditional values and stuff it makes it
a lot harder for you to to move
um and you just got to be aware that if
you
yeah if you do think like this not
everyone's gonna think like that you
know and I I have because I've been in
this a little bit longer so I'm hearing
stories of 20 years 30 years
everything's been good and then people
are saying oh you don't know what she's
done to me
so we just kind of I don't know man I
just
like yeah I guess it's a risky it's a
risk in it it's a risk it's a risk but I
think sorry Paul um what you said before
when we spoke about you said for average
men I think is a very bad like it's not
as good but if you're a
multi-millionaire yeah it's gonna hurt
you but billing you're likely to to be
your right after that and come back but
for someone that you know they haven't
got got to say um the same resources and
then they get divorced at 50 55 and she
takes half and then they have to now
work and you know these are some of the
things that can lead to male suicide and
the stress of it or you know what I mean
so I just think yeah it's a quite a
precarious one
I'd like to get married but I need to be
at a certain point in life before I can
do that I mean like you said if things
go badly you want to know that it's not
going to impact you to the point where
you're down and out so that if it does
go wrong you've still got enough to just
continue and also I think obviously if
you've got kids or if you want to have
kids it plays a big part because I
definitely believe in
I never grew up in that kind of
household but I always felt like I would
have liked to have grown up in a
household with two parents that I
married don't actually see that so I'd
like to give my kids that one so bro um
let's ask you um what what did you feel
that was missing and what did you feel
like at the time of other friends that
had that
just felt like uh just left out and just
like a bit envious yeah little things
like Christmases birthdays where you've
got to choose which parents house you've
got to go to all that kind of stuff
which is a lot nicer to be in a family
unit and seeing like friends that go
home and they've got their mum and dad
in the same household and it's just when
you're growing up you kind of want that
but you can't so I don't know I'd like
to give my kids that
I just you know what it is because I've
had the two pair at home and I know how
it's shaped how I look at things and how
I come into the world it's just that I
always like to ask other people because
I've had my friends that's hard growing
up without it yeah definitely
definitely especially if your parents
don't get on that's the worst because my
mum and my dad didn't get on went up for
it all throughout my childhood so there
was always constant battles of
which parent do you prefer kind of thing
and that impacts the kid do you know
what I mean because
you'd end up feeling guilty a lot of the
time I forgot to choose I got I forgot
to stay with my dad I'll stay with my
mom or
so it's uncomfortable dude and you don't
have to say this if you don't want you
did both of your parents do it what'd
you mean I've just found that like women
seem to do that more did you find that
both they both did it they both hated
each other equally how how would they
put you in the middle of it
uh
the little thing oh mainly mainly
disrespecting each other to me or in
front of me that was the main thing you
know what I mean like they'll be
bitching about each other to me and I'm
just like what are you telling me for
I'm the wrong person
that was the main thing I think
and it kind of it only really stopped as
I got older and then I I was able to
actually level with them and say like
this is ridiculous you need to stop so I
mean and then I think my parents were
really young when they had me as well
like 18 and 21 so they were kids while
we were trying to raise a kid so they
were doing really immature [ __ ] while I
was growing up it's only when they got
older and more mature and wiser than
they actually saw actually this is not
the right way to do things so
we all kind of grew together really
no I've heard that's really common where
like the they'll put the kids in the
middle of it it's not fair to the kids
no no I was the only child who's all
growing up so it was definitely it was
literally the all of the focus was on me
did you did your mom have a did you have
a stepdad figure at home or anything
that too as well so my mom had a
boyfriend from when I was young but then
I never really got on with him because I
knew my dad didn't like him so there was
an instant friction yeah did I mean I
even saw them beefing at one point so it
was all like it was very very messy very
messy so um do you have any sorry tasks
do you have any half sisters I got
horses though how did you feel he
treated you versus his his own
uh no no difference no difference no
but again there's this my sister was
born when I was 11. okay so it was like
I was then raising her with him kind of
yeah yeah I mean it went like a mm-hmm
competition type
did your mom give him like full
authority to like discipline you or was
that a form of friction too
full of worry but he didn't need to if
anything
do you know what it is yeah it's like
with my dad there was a level of
understanding I never crossed the line
with him because I was just more afraid
of seeing him angry whereas my mom she
more than the disciplining but it was
more over the top I mean like the Beats
all that kind of stuff which is like I
mean we've all gone through it you know
I mean it's funny that you say that yeah
and like the same thing with my mom my
dad my dad's never hit me in his life my
dad didn't need to hit me either but I
knew but I knew I didn't want to ever
get to that point and and but my mom for
her whole life would tan me and I'll I
would go back out and do the same thing
yeah the only time that it actually got
to me is when she started learning about
I'm gonna ground you and do some
psychology that was like the worst like
you know like she's like you can't go
and see your friends I was like No just
hit me like
but I've I've discovered something that
that that
which a lot of men don't want to they
don't want to admit because they don't
wanna they don't like saying things
about their mom but we get more Trauma
from our mothers than I feel that we get
from our fathers and if we look at all
the women that are bringing up these
these kids now that doing all the
madness things a lot of them don't have
the father figure and I think the things
that I've struggled with
in my life
um when my father wasn't around my dad
my both my parents were together but
because of his job he was always in the
home so it doesn't matter if your
parents are actually together if he's
not in the home your parents are not
together you're not trying to say to you
because you need to have a man that's in
the home like what you saying so my
dad's job he was always flying across so
what I think is
um when you're growing up as a teen and
then you have a lot of um you have a lot
of testosterone and the same thing um
what's the what's the one that women
produce sorry estrogen estrogen right so
you're being brought by women and I
think a lot of single single mothers
feminize their boys and they don't
actually realize they do it so as you're
growing up you're struggling with your
emotions and now it's quite angry
um and that's the point where a man
would tell you as a man how to handle
these emotions right but you don't have
a man in the home you have a woman that
loves you but she's you know Mommy and
you're making your boy when you have
these boys that go into the world and
they get angry they don't have to handle
the emotion this is a lot of the times
what you hear that these kids do mad
thing and you're like you see I I think
the main thing when the parents are not
together is that there's an equal split
of time spent so like for me I was with
my mom in a week but with my dad at the
weekend so there was very much equal
amount of time spent about you but you
hear these stories where kids don't see
their dads for weeks and months since
mine was longer because it was he was an
African who's back on forth so it was
always that thing where yeah he was
fully in my life and he's there he's
like oh no my mom's in that but he
wasn't there because of his job he was
always moving back and forth so I just
found that that
I suffered for some of the things that
probably some of the other people suffer
from from not having the father that's
there every day he's there but he's not
there every day but your mom's there and
mother's put us through some next
emotional stuff but but for some reason
we we always like try to be like I want
to help my mom but we forget about the
dads but when I look at most of the
trauma that's gone through even with
women women fight their sons all the
time women throughout their daughters
it's very rare that a man would throw
out his daughter or his son because he
would think about all the things that
potentially could happen to his son or
his daughter that's really true I don't
know a single I only know everyone I
mean I don't know many people that were
thrown out but the ones that I do I'm
like they were it was always the mother
I think that's just because women just
act off emotion and men think most
logically so in that instance a man
logically thinking is going to think I'm
not gonna throw my you out because
like bad [ __ ] can happen whereas a woman
might just be acting emotionally at the
time
my mother's feel about treating us a
certain way but we still love them then
we go seeking out the women that will do
similar things as well that will hurt
you and do certain things that you don't
understand why men do this but if you
look at the relationship that some other
some of us had with our mothers and I
love my mum to bits but I'm just talking
about a lot of times women don't realize
that when you're over
um feminize your boys you don't realize
that the boys are supposed to be
masculine and they're supposed to be
learning how to deal with masculinity
and how to deal with their anger issues
and their emotions but when you have a
boy that's in his teens and it hasn't
been taught how to handle his emotions
and he reacts women dealing emotion us
men we think and when you do something
in Emotion that's how you end up doing a
crazy thing and now you're in jail so I
just think that people that's what
happens you know what I mean and it's
just that I think like you know we just
don't speak about some of these things
and the more and more I've been on these
platforms and speaking is I think a
little bit more I'm starting to
understand myself a bit better as well
Paul one thing's about to selected
separately do you think getting beats as
a kin impacted you negatively or
positively
go go get go go get this girl that's
golden thing hold your hand out don't
move if you move it you're gonna get it
again
you know what I think it is I think
because we We're Men you know even
amongst men you know that threat of
violence is always there and even with
boys they can feel it so when a child is
with his Dad he can always feel that
threat of violence if he's messing up
but with women that thing is not there
so it's not real so they have to
actually resort to actual violence would
you hit your kids would you hit your
kids no I really didn't like it I think
for men it's good it kind of I know it
kind of prepares them a bit for that uh
level of you can only get away with so
much before we start throwing hands but
for women it just uh we don't need that
it's harder with girls we don't need
that skill it's not a transferable skill
whereas for you guys it does toughen you
up but for us it's not a transferable
skill we don't need that in the real
world anymore it actually does is makes
you her quick to anger in the real world
and I didn't like it like my mom always
always kind of like she'd always throw
hands and stuff and I felt like it
actually did lead to me being more
masculine when I get into conflict which
I don't think is a good thing
yeah Paul I
so there's a level of African beats
that's just extreme
is is it's but discipline is needed but
I just think there was a level like
because it's mad because my mum how
she's with the grandkids are like they
always suffer it's so it's so weird to
me the way the thing she lets them get
out oh don't hit your kids up I'm like
what Mom the woman that disciplined us
and did all these things now you're with
the grandkids
she just lets him she's like no no let
him beat so I just think that I would do
a level of discipline like if they're
young and they wanna if there's a plug
there and they're gonna do something
different or pick up a knife or you know
what I mean don't do that but the one
where you go out and pick it as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible